while the government's fiscal year 2022
just concluded with record illegal
immigration numbers and the crisis on
our Southern border is front and center
as a major midterm election issue Sarah
Carter has spent significant time on the
border we're talking years and has a new
podcast detailing exactly what she's
found what she's learned she joins us
live Sarah it's great to have you on
there I mean we talked earlier in the
break how you know I started my career
in Yuma Arizona on the border I covered
these issues for decades you have done
the very same and I'm interested from
your perspective and your reporting
what's your biggest takeaway is it the
vast numbers the drugs the death or the
fact that the border is just wide open
it's all of it trace and I I remember
you I remember you covering Yuma I I
remember covering Yuma as well uh
decades ago and I spent the last few
decades covering everything from Central
America through Mexico through our U.S
Southern border but I tell you what I
take away the most from and I hope the
audience understands this this was a
labor of love dark wars pod it's a dark
wars podcast but it's the lies it's the
lies that we are constantly being told
by our government by Foreign governments
about what is happening at our Southern
border this is affecting not only us our
nation but the people who are being
trafficked into our nation and those
lies lead to Deaths deaths here with
over a hundred and seven thousand uh
poisonings and opioid deaths because of
Fentanyl and as well as on the other
side of the Border where we see you know
human trafficking and cartels uh and the
sale of young children and women being
raped those are the lies that we are
being told and and and unfortunately you
know these are the lies that we need to
expose before election because this
should be a bipartisan issue and it
should not be a partisan issue everybody
should agree that our national security
and America needs to come first and I
want to put this up on the screen
because over the past 13 months I mean
this has been the deadliest time for
migrants trying to cross the border look
at that number right there 856 in fiscal
2022 25 just in October so in 13 months
we're talking about
881 migrants who have lost their lives
it's the deadliest time ever ever and
Sarah if president Trump was in office
people would be holding rallies in the
streets down there because they would be
so outraged at what's happening these
people are being raped and they are
being victimized as they come up and
make that journey and they're dying as
they Cross by the hundreds your thoughts
that's absolutely that's absolutely true
trace and those are the people that we
know of there are so many more whose
bodies will never be found or are lost
in the desert and there are so many more
people that are suffering and I hope
that people join us on the podcast
darkwarespod.com and where we expose the
truth and bring you the people that are
going to tell you the truth about what's
happening at our U.S Southern border
yeah you you mentioned how this issue is
really high on the election list and
it's one of the major issues and I want
to play some sound from some of the
debates where they've talked about the
Border we'll get your final response
right
Republicans that have been terrorized by
Donald Trump's immigration policies
won't come across the aisle to do
anything and overdose is 2021 was the
highest number we've ever seen and we
can directly correlate this to the
Whitmer Biden policies of having an open
border we have a catastrophe at the
border and we should not have Sanctuary
cities as John fetterman has tried to
introduce I don't ever recall in the
Statue of Liberty did they say you know
you know take our tired huddle masses
and put them on a bus and use cheap
political stunts about them
I watched these debates almost every
night Sarah and the common denominator
of all of these things are the
Democratic candidates who do not live by
the border and do not know what really
is going down on down there they always
have the same thing as they just don't
quite realize the problem they can't
visualize it they they're not watching
Fox News nobody else is covering it and
so they have answers like this which is
which is somewhat disingenuous your
final thoughts
it's it's absolutely disingenuous it's a
lie the Biden is Administration has
literally done this they have literally
removed any type of law or normalcy On
the Border they have tied the hands of
our law enforcement officials we have
people pouring across the border 98 of
which were on the FBI Terror watch list
that doesn't include over a million
godaways Trace that have come into this
country and this is Biden's policy this
is purposeful it is done on purpose and
this is the reason why the American
people have to be educated they have to
understand what's happening because the
border is no longer at the border trace
the border is in every single state in
every single school and across every
single County in our nation yeah and as
we mentioned a couple of nights ago they
have now seized we're talking about U.S
border agencies enough fentanyl to kill
half the planet it's amazing Sarah
Carter uh best of luck with the podcast
um and thank you for coming on we
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else